sur les indications de Karine Barbour le
couteau est retrouvé chez Christian un
ancien ami de son mari non seulement
cette arme correspond à la à la
morphologie des blessures qui ont été
constatées sur le corps de Marguerite
Lagrave mais qui plusé il est encore 12
ans après porteur de l'ADN de Marguerite
[Applaudissements]
Lagrave 27 novembre 15 cours d'assise
des Pyrénées
Atlantiques ce jour-là la justice va
être rendue à un tout petit village
celui d'Esus à quelques kilomètres de
pot un village où le meurtre mystérieux
d'une vieille dame solitaire a alimenté
les pires
rumeurs jusqu'à accuser injustement
cette femme et son mari qui pendant plus
de 12 ans ont été pris pour
d'abominables criminels
[Musique]
il découvre le le corps de Marguerite
qui git dans une Mar de sang avec la
gorge qui a été transpercé elle a les
yeux suppliciés c'est que son agresseur
lui a enfoncé les deux doigts dans les
yeux de rumeur en rumeur on finit par
entendre dans ce village que Marguerite
avait peut-être des économies elle
cochait une sorte de P
l'inspecteur il voulait que je dise que
c'était mon mari l'assassin dans
l'esprit de tout le monde c'était lui
ils écoutai les rumeurs et ils y
croyaient qu'ils avaient peur et la
rumeur lorsquelle s'installe c'est
catastrophique 12 novembre 2001 ce
matinlà aesus petit paradis perdu au
milieu des Pyrénées personne ne s'attend
à vivre un terrible drame car il y a
quelque chose qui cloche en ce matin
d'automne les volets de la maison de
Marguerite Lagrave restent clos et la
première à s'en étonner est sa
voisine
Marguerite d margaot à l'habitude
d'ouvrir ses volets à partir de 8h or là
il est 9h les volets sont
fermés que spe-t-il qu'est-il arrivé à
margaot pourquoi ne s'est-elle pas
réveillée
alarmé une autre habitante desus vient
aussi au nouvelles et les deux voisines
rongé par l'inquiétude décide
d'agir et comme la porte n'est pas
fermée à clé bien elles vont rentrer
toutes les deux et au moment d'ouvrir la
porte de l'habitation il découvre le
corps de
Marguerite au pied de l'escalier et
quasiment au pas de la
porte
en bas de l'escalier elles vont voir une
scène
épouvantable une vieille femme de 78 ans
qui est toute petite toute frê 1,50 et
qui git dans une marre de sang avec la
la gorge qui lu a été transpercée de
part en part elle est habillée elle
porte une blouse bleue elle git sur le
3/4 3/4 sur le
côté avec beaucoup de sang autour
d'elle prévenu par les deux voisines les
gendarmes de la brigade locale d'Oloron
sainte-mie arrivent les premiers sur les
lieux quelques minutes plus tard et
d'blé un premier élément leur saute aux
yeux il constate qu'il n'y a pas eu des
fractions la porte est
ouverte pas des frractions
mais de toute évidence le ou les tueurs
cherchaient quelque
chose quand les gendarmes rentrent dans
la la maison de Margot Lagrave il voit
que la maison était
dérangée le font en comble la maison été
entièrement entièrement fouillé les
objets ont été
déplacés
minutieusement sur les étagère certains
objets sont retournés les les couvercles
sont ouverts
tout est fouillé tout méthodiquement et
on le sait d'une façon extrêmement
macabre puisque la quasittalité des
objets porte des traces de sang qui sont
le sang de Madame lag grave ce qui
signifie que son agresseur dont les
mains les gants étaient tachés de sang a
farfouiller absolument partout et a
toucher absolument à tous les à tous les
objets mais que cherchait donc le ou les
meurtriers il est un peu trop tôt pour
le
savoir voici Sonia Deger c'est la nièce
de la victime elle n'oubliera pas ce
matin d'automne 2001 qui va à jamais
bouleverser sa vie on était allé boire
le café chez une copine avec ma sœur et
c'est la femme d'un cousin qui a
téléphoné pour nous dire que il y avait
eu un souci avec Tati et et et qu'il
fallait y aller vite donc on est rentré
et là il y avait les pompiers qui nous
ont empêché de rentrer qui ont pas voulu
qu'on la voit après les gendarmes voilà
pareil et en fait on a pas j'ai pas pu
l'avir ni là ni jamais le premier mot
qui venait c'était de dire bon c'était
pour la voler mais elle avait rien et
puis on discutit dus mais on dit mais
c'est pas possible c'était de
l'incompréhension
l'cpréhension toale on sait pas qui a
fait évidemment donc ça peut être
n'importe qui et s revienent ça on sait
pas il fait une fois il peuvent
recommencer donc c'était quand même
terrible tout le monde avait peur un
crime dans ce petit village d'ésus voilà
qui n'est pas banal les quelques 600
habitants sont glacés par la
nouvelle
l'enquête commence vu la gravité des
fait ce sont les gendarmes de la section
de recherche de peau qui seront chargés
de l'enquête et dans un premier temps
c'est la piste du rur qui semble être
privilégié les enquêteurs ils ont essayé
de regarder mais toutes les personnes
qui de près ou de loin ont pu à cette
époque passer par le village ou passer
aux alentours en vain cependant les
gendarmes vont s'intéresser à un groupe
de randonneur qui sillonnaent la région
à l'époque des
[Musique]
faits les
gendarmes apprennent qu'il y avait une
marche en direction de Saint-Jacques de
Compostelle les enquêteurs sont allés
jusqu'à les retrouver euh pour les
interroger pour vérifier donc leur
emploi du temps et pour vérifier qu'il
n'étaient pas impliqués dans dans dans
ce
crime tous les marcheurs ont été
entendus ils ont tous des explications à
donner et cette piste s'arrête là alors
si ce n'est pas un rodeur qui a tué
Marguerite
lave les gendarmes décident d'entendre
un par un tous les habitants de ce petit
village d'ésus et ces auditions vont
porter leur
fruits les gendarmes vont retrouver
trois témoins qui tous affirment avoir
vu une Golfe noire avec un liseret rouge
elle a été aperçue par les voisins la
veille au soir à l'heure supposé du
crime ces trois témoins affirment avoir
vu une voiture stationnée à une dizaine
de mètres de la maison de margaot tout
far
allumé seulement lorsqu'il s'agit de
décrire le conducteur les déclarations
des voisins sont beaucoup plus
floues ce sont des témoignages dont la
fiabilité est sujette à contestation
puisque il y a des couleurs de véhicules
qui correspondent pas toujours selon les
témoins la silhouette des personnes que
l'on aperçoit n'est pas toujours la même
certains ont vu une femme d'autres ont
vu un homme on parle de quelqu'un de
forte
corpulence pour l'un elle est blonde
l'autre est brune dès lors les gendarmes
vont s'attacher à retrouver la voiture à
liser rouge tous les propriétaires de ce
type de véhicule dans la région sont
entendus mais forcé de constater que
chacun d'entre eux a un alibi la piste
de la voiture sombre au liseret rouge
est
abandonnée pour le
moment et c'est l'autopsie qui va venir
relancer
l'enquête
au centre hospitalier de peau le médecin
légiste vient de terminer son rapport et
d'après lui le meurtre de Marguerite
Lagrave a été d'une violence
inouï il fait état de vertèbres qui ont
été sectionné et d'une plie au niveau de
de la gorge qui est extrêmement profonde
et qui a été pratiqué avec un couteau
tranchant de large et de manière très
violente on va constater également
qu'elle a de nombreuxes équiboses et de
nombreus PL sur le visage notamment sur
les yeux et on va trouver quelqu'un qui
a de multiples
traumatismes ces blessures laissent
penser que la vieille dame de 78 ans
s'est batue avant de mourir il y a une
bagarre très vraisemblablement elle a de
nombreuses échimoses elle a le sternom
et des côtes
elle a les yeux suppliciés c'estàdire
que son agresseur lui a enfoncé les deux
doigts dans les yeux on a le sentiment
hein que cet enfoncement des yeux doit
signifier quelque chose en terme de
volonté de ne pas être vu de ne pas être
reconnu une porte sans trace
d'effraction des yeux suppliciers pour
les gendarmes tout porte désormais à
croire que le meurtrier savait qui était
Marguerite
et cela va tout changer pour
l'enquête car cela veut dire que la
vieille dame a certainement été tué par
quelqu'un du
village cela faisait 70 ans que
Marguerite vivait ici à Esus alors
forcément tout le monde la
connaissait pour autant la vieille dame
était un peu sauvage
et ne voyait pas grand
[Musique]
monde voit personne juste les gens qui
passaient devant la maison recevait
personne elle vivait avec ses souvenirs
mais c'est tout
quoi Marguerite LAGRA vivait dans une
véritable
solitude on sait qu'elle n'a donc jamais
eu d'enfant qu'elle a toujours été
célibataire mais en fait on sait très
peu de choses sur
alors pouvait-elle attirer la convoitise
de ses voisins tout porte à croire que
non elle vivait au cœur d'ésus dans
cette petite maison qui semble quelque
peu délabrée
elle vit dans des conditions qui sont
sans doute proches de celles qu'ont
connu ses parents et peut-être ses ses
grands-parents à inérieur extrêmement
extrêmement modeste le sol s'était
interbattu av toilette dehors et pas de
salle de bain il y avait un robinet
d'eau froide une ampoule électrique
c'est tout on pouvait rien brancher et
en haut cé à la chandelle elle voulait
pas de confort ses frères voulaient lui
mettre le confort elle a jamais
voulu d'après sa famille marguerite
n'avait donc pas un
S seulement certains habitants du
village desus ne sont pas du tout du
même avis de rumeur en rumeur on finit
par entendre dans ce village que
Marguerite La Grave avait peut-être des
économies peut-être un bas de laine
parce que ces 3600 francs qu'elle
touchait à l'époque de pension on sait
qu'elle dépensait pas tout finalement
affichant un train de vie si si modeste
en réalité elle cochait une sorte de PCT
le possible trésor de Marguerite
alimente toutes les conversations et
nombreux sont ceux dans le village qui
soupçonnent les membres de la famille de
la vieille dame d'en vouloir
Mago d'ailleurs les gendarmes ont dans
le colimateur un
couple Sonia la nièce de la victime et
son mari
Bruno à l'époque du drame ils avaient
des problèmes d'argent ils auraient très
bien pu éliminer margaot pour éponger
leur dettes ils ont décidé que on avait
des graves problèmes financiers qu'on
pouvait pas acheter avec trois enfants
donc ça ne p n Bruno est ouvrier Bruno
est marié avec Sagia et ils ont des
difficultés financièr ils viennent
d'acheter une maison il il tire le
diable par la queue et donc il peut
faire figure de suspect et le problème
c'est que Bruno le mari de Sonia n'a pas
un alibi solide pour le soir du
crime ce jour-là il était seul chez lui
à faire des travaux de
rénovation
c'est pas un alibit dire qu'on est chez
soi en train de travailler ou de
bricoler et que personne ne peut peut en
intester ça peut ça peut effectivement
prêter une quelconque
suspicion les gendarmes décident de
jouer le tout pour le
tout il place en garde à vue Sonia et
Bruno avec une idée en tête les faire
craquer quand ils me disent maintenant
vous êtes en garde à vue on
perquisitionne il faut que vous soyez là
et après on voilà ils m'ont embarqué non
mais ça n tombe sur nous tombe sur la
tête quoi on s'attend pas du tout à ça
nous on a rien fait on a rien
demandé juste avoir la
paix mais ça c'est pas possible les
enquêteurs pensent que si Bruno est le
meurtrier sonia est forcément au courant
il décide donc de mettre la pression sur
son
épouse l'inspecteur il voulait que je
dise que cétait Mar l'assassin mais je
pouvais pas dire que c'était lui puis
que c'était pas
lui donc et tout le temps il revenait là
dessus et mais non face au gendarmes
Sonia se défend pour elle la théorie du
trésor caché de Margerite est le fruit
de l'imagination des mauvaises langues
du village il y avait pas de trésor dans
sa maison ma tante vivait avec le font
national de
solidarité à l'époque c'était quoi 3600
francs elle n'avait pas d'argent et elle
nous rapportait à la limite plus vivante
que morte puisque vivante il suffisait
d'aller la voir et elle nous le donnait
une fois morte c'était fini malgré de
longues heures d'audition ni Sonia ni
Bruno ne vont craquer et il le jure ils
n'ont pas tué Marguerite il n'avouera
jamais avoir participé à quoi que ce
soit sa propre femme Sonia le défend bec
et
ongles priori ça colle pas quoi ils
l'ont longuement longuement travaillé
comme on dit hein ils ont vraiment cru
qu'il tenait le qu'il tenait le bon
gars le couple est relâché aucune charge
ne sera retenue contre
eux la victime était tellement pauvre
avait une pension de de retraite
tellement maudique que le le mobile lié
à l'argent ne tient pas un seul
instant mais aesus la nouvelle de la
garde à vue a fait le tour du village
aux yeux de tous Bruno est le meurtrier
de Marguerite la
grave dans l'esprit de tout le monde
c'était lui et plus le temps passait et
plus c'était lui et il s'en sortait bien
et la rumeur lorsqu'elle s'installe
c'est catastrophique il est certain que
le fait que les enquêteurs ne trouvent
pas le coupable entretenu l'idée chez
certaines personnes chez certains
habitants du village que bah que ils
s'en étaient bien tirer il y en a
beaucoup dans le village qui ne nous
disaient plus bonjour alors
que il y en a je suis du village moi
enfin je suis né là quoi
donc tous les anciens me connaissent euh
non ça y est il ne disait plus bonjour
où c'était des des sourirs très distants
enfin je comprenais
pas après j'ai
compris et en fait c'était parce que j'
avais mis l'étiquette sur Bruno tout
simplement c'était l'assassin et puis
voilà ils écoutai les rumeurs et ils y
croyaient donc ils avaient peur il y a
des gamins qui all à l'école des gamins
de la famille
larave
camarades trait le fils
d'assassin ça ça été parmi les
témoignages paroles les plus
[Musique]
fortes le poids du
soupçon Sonia et sa famille vont le
porter pendant presque 12 ans sans
jamais pouvoir s'en défaire
cependant un an après le meurtre de
Marguerite Lagrave le meurtrier court
toujours pendant des années les
gendarmes de la brigade de recherche de
peau continuent de travailler sur ce
dossier sans
succès en septembre 2005 4 ans après la
mort de Marga faute nouveau le juge
d'instruction décide de prononcer un nom
lieu ce crime va rester un col caisse
dans le
village alimentant évidemment toutes les
rumeurs qu'on peut imaginer les uns
continuent à être persuadés que c'est
Bruno d'autres ont leurs idées aussi
là-dessus la mort de cette femme reste
gravée dans les mémoires des villageois
j'en connais certains qui ont qui ont
barricadé leur maison qui ont fait
mettre des SP et cetera bon est-ce que
ça aurait changé quelque chose dans
l'esprit de quelqu'un qui avait vraiment
décidé de passer à l'acte chez cette
personne je sais pas ça on peut pas dire
mais derrière ça montre quand même que
ça arrivé même chez
nous le meurtre de Marguerite larave
tombe peu à peu dans les oubliettes
judiciaires alors que son fantôme
continue à hanter le village
d'ésus 12 années vont succéder jus oup
de
théâtre
incroyable mars 2013 une femme vient se
présenter à la gendarmerie de lacano sur
la côte atlantique à 250 km desus
elle vient déposer
plainte une dame s'est présentée à la
gendarmerie de lacano en
Gironde pour dénoncer un certain nombre
de choses dans dans un contexte bien
particulier de conflit avec son
ex-mi cette femme s'appelle Karine
Barbour elle a 35 ans et elle est
coiffeuse ce jour-là elle vient déposer
plainte contre son ex-mi Daniel
treille selon elle cet homme se serait
montré violent à son encontre et la
jeune femme se dit en
danger alors kine Barbour va se
présenter comme une femme battue comme
une femme qui a subi euh véritablement
pendant toute sa vie maritale la
violence de son mari l'alcoolisation de
son mari et qui a subi sans sans rien
dire pendant des années euh qui a élevé
ses enfants qui qui est restéit à la
maison qui qui a travaillé et qui s'est
retrouvé avec un homme qui l' battait
régulièrement et avec personne pour
l'aider et la mère de famille devant les
gendarmes va plus loin elle va révéler
un terrible
secret Karine Barbour va dire à cette
femme gendarme que elle est menacée de
mort qu'elle a peur pour sa vie parce
que son mari est un tueur
[Musique]
elle sait que son ancien
compagnon a commis un crime horrible euh
dans le village jus quelques années
auparavant que elle sait que c'est lui
qui qui est coupable de ce
crime ce jour-là Karine repart de la
gendarmerie de lacano persuadé qu'avec
ses révélations les gendarmes vont
s'occuper de son ex-mi Daniel treille
ainsi elle espère obtenir la garde
exclusive de ses
enfants
le 28 mars 2013 le parquet de peau est
aussitôt avisé de ces nouveaux élément
le procureur de la République décide
alors deouvrir le dossier Marguerite
larave donc moi je considère que c'est
un élément nouveau et c'est un élément
nouveau qui va permettre de reprendre où
on les avait laissé en 2005 les
investigations sur la mort de Madame
larave
et aux enquêteurs de la section de
recherche de peau de se replonger dans
le dossier La
Grave et la surprise ils vont
s'apercevoir que Karine
Barbour n'est pas une
inconnue il y a quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire dans ce dossier c'est
que Karine Barbour avait été entendu en
2001 au lendemain du crime parce qu'elle
habitait Esus et donc comme tous les
habitants des US elle avait été entendue
et si à l'époque les enquêteurs ont
auditionné Karine c'est parce que la
jeune femme possédait une voiture sombre
avec un liseret rouge comme celle
souvenez-vous qui avait été aperçu par
les voisins à proximité du domicile de
margaot lag grarave le soir du
meurtre on s'aperçoit aussi qu'elle est
de forte corpulence puisquelle fait 160
kg un témoin avait d'ailleurs raconté
avoir aperçu au volant de cette voiture
une femme de forte
corpulence et à l'époque ça n'avait pas
interpellé les gendarmes ils étaient
passés à
côté au lendemain du crime ils ont ils
ont ils ont des éléments je je je suis
pas capable de vous expliquer comment
ils ont pu passer à côté de ça c'est
incompréhensible tout était devant leur
nez une habitante
kine avec une morphologie qui ressemble
à la description faite par les
témoins une golf au liser rouge 12 ans
après le crime sauvage de Marguerite
larave les éléments du puzzle commencent
à se mettre en
place dans le petit village tout le
monde connaî Karine Barbour et son mari
Daniel il vivait àus et de la vie de
tous ce couple un peu spécial n'a jamais
su s'intégrer à la
population lui est décrit comme un
ouvrier
manutentionnaire il est sous sous
curatel c'est un homme dont la vie est
une existence précaire il faut savoir
qu'elle va se marier donc avec Daniel
trille qui est son premier amour à 22
ans elle se marie elle n'a connu
personne d'autre que Daniel try euh
et elle a une personnalité qui donc
correspond un tout petit peu à cela
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui est recentré
sur sa maison sur son couple puis
ensuite sur ses enfants et qui n'a pas
véritablement de vie sociale à
l'extérieur en fait c'est une c'est un
c'est un c'est un tyran cette femme elle
va le chercher dans le bistro alors
qu'il est avec ses copains en train de
boire un coup elle le sort manuilitar du
café quand elle considère qu'il y a pas
c trop de temps elle hésite pas à
l'assommer à moitié avec un tuyau
d'arrosage quand il est avec son voisin
à discuter trop
longtemps en 2001 l'année du drame
Karine et Daniel avaient deux enfants en
basâge et à cette époque le couple était
financièrement au bord du
gaufre on sait que dans les mois qui
précédait les fait le couple était en
proie à des difficultés financières
Karine Barbour dépensait sans compter
elle était un petit peu la la madame
bovarie de de la vallé d'ASP alors la
rumeur alimentée par les gens du village
concernant le badeline de Marguerite
leur aurait-elle donné des
idées le trésor de margaot était-il la
solution à leur problème c'est en tout
cas pour les enquêteurs le mobile qu'il
manquait
en juillet 2013 les gendarmes décident
donc de placer sur écout Karine Barbour
l'objectif en savoir plus sur cette
femme et sur son
exmi et les enquêteurs vont découvrir
que les deux anciens amants sont
vraisemblablement impliqué dans le
crime com témoigne une conversation
téléphonique entre Daniel
etine explique à à try que elle a
rendez-vous à la gendarmerie elle lui
dit tu sais pour le meurtre
donc on on l'entend mal mais on sent
qu'il y a un moment de recul et il dit
ah oui et quoi qu'est-ce que tu vas dire
elle dit mais oui tu sais bien le
meurtre celui de margaot lag grave en
2001 on voit Karine Barbour qui essaie
de faire chanter Daniel Trey en lui
rappelant de manière mais en jouant
quasiment en avec des mots un peu crus
mais tu te souviens euh euh la petite
vieille hein le meurtre je vais raconter
et lui à cette réponse extraordinaire il
lui euh n'oublie pas que tu étais avec
moi et que tu es aussi mouillé que
moi pour les enquêteurs cela ne fait
plus aucun doute Karine Barbour ne leur
a pas tout dit et la suite de l'enquête
va drresser un portrait de cette mère de
famille
assoifffé par le désir de
[Musique]
vengeance en effet les écoutes n'ont pas
fini d'étonner les
gendarmes il y a deux autres
conversations qui ont été interceptées
dans le cadre des écoutes téléphoniques
qui sont très intéressantes pour
l'enquête la première c'est lorsqu'elle
appelle une journaliste de Sud-Ouest en
lui disant qu'elle a un
scoop cette journaliste la
voici
elle se souvient parfaitement du jour où
Karine Barbour l'a contacté
elle voulait me parler d'une très
vieille histoire très vieille affaire
qui s'était passée à Isus en 2001 à
savoir le meurtre d'une d'une vieille
dame elle a poursuivi la la discussion
en m'expliquant que
elle était elle-même en fait menacée par
la personne qui avait commis ce crime à
savoir son ex-mi qu' visiblement menacé
de lui faire la même chose qu'à la
vieille Karine Barbour explique à la
journaliste qu'elle a déjà dénoncé
Daniel tre auprès de la gendarmerie sans
résultat c'est pourquoi elle choisit
maintenant d'alerter la presse et la
jeune femme ne va pas s'arrêter là elle
va également tenter de faire peur à
Daniel TR en le dénonçant pour le
meurtre de Marguerite auprès de sa
propre
famille elle va appeler la mère de son
ex-mi donc la la maman de Daniel tra et
là elle se fait passer pour la
journaliste de Sud-Ouest qu'elle vient
d'avoir au téléphone d'ailleurs en lui
disant voilà je suis journaliste à
sud-ouest j'ai besoin de renseignement
concernant votre fils parce qu'il est
mêlé dans une affaire de meurtre à
Esus la jeune femme ne sait pas qu'elle
est sur écoute et elle ne sait pas non
plus que les gendarmes enquêtent sur le
crime de Marguerite laag
convaincu que Karine Barbour et Daniel
try sont impliqué dans les faits les
enquêteurs vont abattre leur dernière
carte Karine est convoquée à la
gendarmerie encore une fois elle
maintient ses déclarations son ex-mi est
responsable de la mort de Marguerite
Lagrave et sans se douter que les
enquêteurs la soupçonnent comme son
ex-mi la jeune femme va fournir au
gendarmes la preuve irréfutable de la
culpabilité de Daniel trille
[Applaudissements]
elle va donner des précisions sur l'arme
qui était un couteau que le le le couple
possédaé qui avait été acheté en Espagne
par elle-même titre de cadeau dit-elle
c'est une arme qui qui é de taille assez
importante et elle va don une précision
à savoir que ce couteau a été après le
le meurtre a été offert à un ami par
Daniel
tril comme comme cadeau et les les les
gendarmes vont se rendre au domicile de
cette personne et vont effectivement
retrouver ce
couteau sur les indications de Karine
Barbour le couteau est retrouvver chez
Christian un ancien ami de son
mari l'arme
expertisé et les résultats sont sans
appel non seulement cette arme
correspond à à la à la morphologie des
blessures qui ont été constatées sur le
corps de Marguerite Lagrave mais qui
plus est il est encore 12 ans après
porteur de l'ADN de Marguerite larave
c'est quelque chose d'incroyable c'est
que on retrouve sur le couteau bah
l'ADN évidemment du sang de la victime
mais également des traces ADN de de
Daniel Trey donc cette arme du crime va
permettre de le confondre et de forger
en tout cas chez les enquêteurs une
certitude sur son implication dans dans
le
crime le 9 septembre 2013 Daniel try est
placé en garde à vue et immédiatement
l'homme va soulager sa
conscience 12 ans après le crime il va
livrer le a de cette nuit sanglante de
novembre
2001 celui d'un homme aux abois poussé à
bout par sa propre femme il dit surtout
que c'est elle qui lu a dit bon
maintenant on a on a pas d'argent il
faut faire un cass on va on va aller
chez chez margaot
va lancer cette idée elle dit il y a de
l'argent je connais une dame qui a de
l'argent on va y aller il y a aucun
risque et elle elle commence à à je
dirais à lui mettre cette idée
une date est fixée et un scénario se met
en
place le soir du meurtre le couple
accompagné de leurs deux enfants monte
dans la Golfe noire au liseret rouge
c'est Karine qui est au
volant il explique
que sa sa compagne le
conduit à proximité du lieu du crime et
que les deux enfants sont à l'arrière de
la
voiture visiblement la présence des deux
enfants ne le dissuade en rien dans la
voiture Karine Barbour lui aurait alors
ordonné de se munir de gants
polaire et de prendre un couteau dans la
boîte à gant pourquoi prend-il le
couteau il nous explique que c'est
Karine qui lui aurait demandé à
plusieurs reprises prends-le au cas où
Daniel TR nous dit elle me dit tu prends
un couteau on sait jamais pour lui c'est
c'est fin norement un couteau ça peut
servir à ouvrir une porte qui est fermée
et dès qu'il quitte la voiture pour se
rendre donc dans la maison de de margaot
elle et c'est là qu'elle va être vue par
les trois fameux témoins elle va
remonter avec sa voiture parce qu'on est
dans une impasse donc elle va remonter
avec la voiture faire une sorte de
demi-tour en haut et se garer à côté de
l'école de son côté Daniel Trey raconte
qu'il serait entré dans la maison de
Marguerite
s la moindre
difficulté Daniel TR nous dit que qu'il
est rentré que la porte était
ouverte qu'il a même pas la forcer ce
qui est pratique il va se retrouver dans
cette pièce qui est vide si l'on en
croit ces déclarations Daniel TR va
alors commencer à fouiller les pièces du
rez-de-chaussée à la recherche du trésor
de
Marguerite seulement les choses ne vont
pas tout à fait se passer comme
prvu il va entendre du du bruit à
l'étage et très vite il va se retrouver
alors qu'il est dans dans dans cette
pièce il va se retrouver avec Margerite
larave qui descend il a un petit
escalier et qui est dans l'escalier face
à
lui et là il va se retrouver en panique
complète il va essayer de s'enfuir
ça va paniquer il va y avoir une lutte
et puis à l'occasion de cette lutte
alors que manifestement il doit avoir le
dessus sur cette femme qui est âgée de
près de 80 ans alors que lui en a une
trentaine il s'est fait en poigner il
est tombé sur la victime en lui
assainant en lui portant le coup de
couteau de manière involontaire donc lui
ce qu'il va dire c'est que il a porté un
coup involontaire que le coup est parti
tout seul et qu'il n'a pas
maîtrisé alors Daniel va va va se
retrouver sur Marguerite lagrade et
effectivement il va il va constater que
qu'elle est
morte dans les locaux de la gendarmerie
Daniel tre ne peut expliquer pourquoi à
ce moment-là alors que Marguerite j au
milieu d'une marre de sang il continue
sa basse
besogne il va se relever et là je crois
que ce qui reprend le dessus c'est
finalement l'emprise de Karim Barbour
par ce qui va dire il faut que je ramène
quelque chose c'est ce qu'il dit il faut
que je ramène l'argent il faut que je
ramène ce ce qu'il fallait que je ramène
et il va fouiller la maison et notamment
l'étage il va monter à l'étage et il va
fouiller les tiroirs il va fouiller les
meubles et on va retrouver effectivement
des traces
de des traces de sang qui
sur le sur le le mobilier ou sur le sol
de la maison de Marguerite mais voilà
Daniel try ne pas avoir trouvé l'argent
de
Marguerite alors Daniel TR sort de de la
maison retrouve Karine Barbour et tout
de suite lui dit mais mais je il lui
explique en de mots il lui dit j'ai rien
elle est morte je l'ai tué elle ma
surpris je l'ai tué et là elle lui
aurait répondu t'inquiète pas tu dis
rien je m'occupe de
tout ils sont rentrés chez
eux le lendemain matin ils vont se
débarrasser à la fois des gants en
polaire pas de tout ce qu'il avait sur
lui pour commettre ce cambriolage ils
vont à la à la déchetterie du coin et le
couteau l'arme du crime ils vont
l'offrir à leur ami Christian
le couple aurait ensuite laissé passer
les mois et les années sans éveiller
aucun
soupçon le 11 septembre 2013 Daniel Trey
est mis en examen pour
meurtre le lendemain Karine Barbour est
poursuivi pour complicité de tentatives
de vol avec
armes tous les deux sont incarcérés à la
maison d'arrêt de pont
[Musique]
ce qu'on retient c'est que
c'est aussi incroyable que ça puisse
paraître ça aurait pu être le crime
parfait sans le faire
exprès dans le village desésus des
bruits circule le meurtrier de margaot
aurait enfin été arrêté et contre toute
attente ce n'est pas Bruno ou Sonia que
beaucoup
soupçonnent mais tout le village est
stupéfait d'apprendre que le meurtrier
saomlice était néanmoins connu de tous
au départ on y croit pas tout à fait la
PremièreAction c'est pas possible parce
qu'en plus ils ont vécu pendant pas 12
ans puisquils se sont séparés avant mais
ils ont vécu au moins 5 6 ans après au
milieu de tout le monde et bonjour
bonsoir non jamais non pas possible nous
on a su en le 13 septembre je crois que
c'était c'est Bruno qui m'a appelé je
partais au boulot il me dit ils ont
trouvé les assassins de ta tante c'est
dans le journal
oh j'ai fait demi-tour j'ai dit tant pis
même si je suis en retard je vais me
chercher le journal et donc là j'étais
sous le choc toute la
journée si sonia est soulagée elle est
toutefois perplexe face à l'hypothèse du
cambriolage qui mal tourné car elle
connaissait les habitudes de margaot et
il y a quelque chose qui cloche dans le
récit du
meurtrier que ma tante n'it pas fermé sa
porte c'est pas possible la porte devait
être
fermée à mon avis c'était fermé par
contre quand on y allait tapit elle
demandait qui c'était et elle ouvrait la
fenêtre elle ouvrait les volets elle ouv
la fenêtre regarder referm et elle
allait ouvrir la
porte donc pour moi il s'est présenté
après je sais pas j'étais pas avec lui
mais pour moi il s'est présenté il y a
pas de trace de frraction parce qu'elle
a ouvert la porte cette thèse du
cambriolage qui tourne mal c'est de la
fouaise n'oubliez pas qu'il vient à
visage découvert il n'est pas
qu'agoulé il a sans doute pris des gants
pour ne pas laisser d'empreinte mais il
n'est pas qu'agoul
or
imaginez que il tombe nez à nez avec
elle ce qui était un scénario prévisible
à
99,99 % prendrait-il le risque alors
qu'il l'a déjà croisé prendrait-il le
risque d'être dénoncé par cette petite
mamie Daniel tre essaie-t-il de
minimiser son acte avait-il en fait
l'intention d'éliminer Marguerite quel
était le plan qu'il avait élaboré avec
Karine
Barbour toujours est-il que face au juge
d'instruction Daniel tre maintiendra ses
déclarations
le procès de Karine Barbour et Daniel
try s'ouvre le 27 novembre 2015 devant
la Cour d'Assise des Pyrénées
Atlantiques les habitants du petit
village d'ésus se sont déplacés pour
l'occasion vous aviez tout un village
toute une vallée qui qui assistait et
toute une famille bien évid mais qui a
assisté au procès parce que on sent
qu'il y a une sorte de délivrance de
voir enfin les véritables
coupa identifié et poursuivi jugé donc
je crois que ça les habitant en avaiit
besoin quelque part
pour tourner la page et pour retourner à
une vie normale pour Sonia celle qui au
départ a été accusée ce procès est une
dévrance il y a plus d'angoisse demain
j'irai en prison parce que demain on
peut pas nous dire que c'est nous non
c'est pas
nous non pour cette affaire là non c'est
fini mais après on se dit que avec une
rumeur on y vite dans le box des accusés
Karine et Daniel Trey n'ont plus aucun
regard l'un pour
l'autre c'est un procès qui s'annonce
difficile parce que on a bien
l'impression que il va y avoir des
rapports de force très très endu entre
les deux accusés le couple s'est
complètement disloqué Karine Barbour et
Daniel try ne se parlent pas il néchange
pas un mot on sent qu'il y a un froid
glacial c'est sûr que c'est c'était
quelque chose d'assez impressionnant de
les voir ne pas échanger un regard ne
pas échanger une parole et de les voir
braquer l'un contre l'autre mais en même
temps avec leur destin
scellé pendant la cour d'assise on avait
encore devant nous et Daniel trille et
Karine Barbour et ce fameux 3e
personnage qui était le couple qu'il
formait C espèce de couple assez
mystérieux face au juré Karine Barbour
et Daniel treille vont camper sur leur
position Karine Barbour
elle s'exprime facilement
euh et elle s'exprime peut-être d'autant
plus facilement que Daniel try
s'exprime difficilement et peu au cours
du procès elle reste sur la ligne qui a
été la sienne son mari était un
alcoolique invétéré pendant le temps de
leur mariage il était parfois violent
euh
elle était plutôt soumise et faisait ce
qu'on lui demandait de faire et ça c'est
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé bon
tout le dossier dit le contraire mais
elle s'est tenu à cette à cette
[Musique]
version le procès de Karine Barbour et
Daniel Trey prend fin le 1er décembre
2015 au terme d'un délibéré de 2h les
jurés rendent leur
verdict Daniel Trey est condamné à 20
ans de prison pour
meurtre Karine Barbour et C de 13 ans
pour complicité de tentativ de vol pour
moi le meurtre desus c'est au vu de ce
qui s'est passé pendant tout le procès
c'est un crime gratuit commis par des
gens qui ont on cru que ils allaient
trouver un magot chez la personne mais
la plus humble la plus modeste et la
plus pauvre de tout le village donc
c'est quelque chose
d'absolument gratuit idiot et bête
Karine Barbour et le parquet font
immédiatement appel de la décision il y
aura donc un nouveau
procès
[Musique]
aesus pour son